it's great to welcome back to the
program today tom hartman tom hosts the
thom hartmann program and is also author
of the hidden history series the latest
book in that series is the hidden
history of neoliberalism how reaganism
gutted america and how to restore its
greatness tom always great having you on
thank you david thanks for inviting me
so um one of the interesting things
about reaganism is i don't think this is
the first time that we can say this but
there were sort of certain stories that
started to be told which shifted the way
that in large part uh corporate and
political media talked about politics uh
we know about the welfare queen stories
we we know about a lot of these
different stories that's overtly or
sometimes not so overtly were used
to shift our focus about how we should
think about politics welfare programs
etc can you talk a little bit about the
the circumstances in which this shift
from keynesianism to neoliberalism took
place and if you want to also define
neo-liberalism as you use the term in
the book that would be great too sure
yeah neoliberalism was a political and
economic philosophy that was originated
in europe in the nineteen forties in an
effort to come up with a system a
political system that governments could
use that would prevent them from ever
becoming fascist or communist this was
in the wake of you know world war ii
and uh
you know sadly
neoliberalism every time it's been
applied it's been applied to a country
um one of two things has happened
first of all it always flips the country
into oligarchy which is a very unstable
political system you and i talked about
when my book on oligarchy came out of
rarely last more than a generation or
two it's so unstable and oligarchy
typically either flips into fascism
as it has in russia as it did in iraq
and and over the short term well over
the short term actually what happened in
chile was the uh the other alternative
which is that it flips uh oligarchy
flips into
democracy which is what happened when
they overthrow overthrew pinochet
so the united states now is still in
this neoliberal phase this 40-year
neoliberal experiment and we've got
enormous pressures coming out of the
republican party to turn america into a
fascist state an enormous pressure from
the democratic party to turn america
into a democratic state small d
and uh or you could say democratic
republic
um the definition of neoliberalism is
pretty straightforward these guys
believed that because there's billions
of decisions being made in the
marketplace every second i mean right
now there's probably a thousand people
in this literally as we're speaking
choosing which brand of orange juice to
buy um you know there's just billions of
decisions being made in the marketplace
and that they saw as a huge collective
wisdom and therefore they said the
marketplace should be defining the rules
of the marketplace and and also the
rules of governance which traditionally
define the rules of the marketplace now
this in and of itself is an insane idea
it's like saying you know if
i mean the marketplace is nothing more
than a game that we play that involves
money just like football is a game that
we play that involves this ball made out
of pigskin and you know this is like
saying well what the nfl should do is
whichever team has the most money should
just let them write the rules and decide
how many men they can have on the field
during the game and how many their
competitors must have because they're in
charge now basically neoliberalism
always leads to the rise of billionaire
oligarchs and the massive consolidation
of huge corporations at the expense of
small communities in small businesses so
number one low taxes cut because because
the billionaires and the big
corporations are the major players in
the economy they need to be encouraged
because they're the darwinian winners so
that's why we have a three percent
income tax rate right now for
billionaires and thirty percent for you
and me um uh number number ten and we've
got two two men now who control more
than half a half ha have more wealth in
the bottom half of america number two uh
so-called free trade corporations should
be free to go anywhere in the world and
find the cheapest labor possible because
nations don't matter to hell with
nations although a nation should keep
people within their borders
they shouldn't keep corporations within
their borders
and uh you know there's a bunch of
corollaries to that
um you know that uh
you know kind of derive out of those
basic oh and and that labor is always an
interference in the marketplace any
labor d you know if labor has power that
distorts the marketplace because labor
isn't the major player labor is just
subordinate to management and therefore
all me labor unions should be destroyed
so reagan adopted this and applied it to
the united states through us into
neoliberalism took us out of classic
adam smith economics what sometimes
referred to as keynesian economics
because john maynard keynes had
fine-tuned it but really it's what uh
particularly in his book a theory of
moral sentiments in 1784 that adam smith
described in some detail
before uh
let me pause there so before we move on
into more of the history now that you've
kind of defined it for us um there are
some in my audience who are
uh
further to to the left that than i am
certainly and and are truly sort of bona
fide socialists and i don't use that
term pejoratively who sometimes will
write to me and they'll say you know
david there's really not that much
breathing room between
neo-liberalism as you've just defined it
and written about and northern european
social democracy it's all way too far to
the right for them can you weigh in a
little bit on
is there really substantive difference
between what you just defined and
northern european social democracy or
are they more similar maybe than some of
us like to acknowledge
well first of all if you compare you
know pinochet's chile or russia
uh or iraq where where nouriel milikey
has turned himself into basically you
know
a dictator
um yeah there's some significant
differences between those countries in
any country in europe that said uh
margaret thatcher was the f you know i
mean neoliberalism was invented in the
forties these guys pitched it
aggressively through the fifties and
sixties and largely were considered
crackpots
and then we got the inflation of the 70s
as a result of the arab oil embargo in
73 in the fall of the shaw in 79 and
that inflation uh was the perfect uh
tool or
opportunity that milton friedman used
here in the united states to pitch
neoliberalism not just here but all
around the world he said neoliberalism
will fix inflation which hadn't even
been part of the original sales pitch
but hey you know take opera this is
naomi klein's shock doctrine right you
got a problem we got a solution
and so uh margaret thatcher was actually
the first to buy it
and you know broke the coal union which
was the strongest union in all of the
united kingdom nobody thought it was
even possible in her first months in
office and and and uh and then you know
privatized the railroad and did a whole
bunch of other neoliberal reforms
so the uk uh is not that far behind the
united states in terms of neoliberalism
we're we're only farther ahead because
we were more neoliberal to begin with we
didn't have a national health service we
didn't have free college um you know we
didn't have the basic stuff that england
has a strong a strong really strong
welfare state
um so you know yeah neoliberalism has
infected europe and uh some
so-called neoliberal reforms most of
them being pushed by the imf by the way
and being trumpeted at davos every year
by all the billionaires who show up
have crept into
many of the european countries in
particular france
um and and the united kingdom as i just
mentioned
but uh and and and you know there's even
a debate about neoliberalism in sweden
right now but um but to say that it's
the same thing no that's that's just
not right you know one of the
interesting things about
uh the replacement of keynesianism by
neoliberalism relates to this idea that
keynes had in the 30s and if you've read
anything about leisure economics or this
this always comes up keynes had this
idea
that soon we would all be working only
15 hours a week and people would have
all of this leisure time because of
technology and productivity etcetera
etcetera and of course we know it didn't
happen we know that actually the work
week continue to get longer and longer
would keynes maybe have been right were
it not for neo-liberalism because it's
so it's so discussed
that was keynes's prediction we know it
didn't happen there's 50 different
explanations as to why is neoliberalism
a part of that
uh to an extent yeah i mean you know
look at france when when they adopted
fully adopted essentially what you're
calling keynesianism after world war ii
um you know uh they they were able to
get legally get down to a maximum 30
hour or maybe it was 32 hour work week
as you'll recall i mean that was a big
deal um italy adopted that although they
didn't make it law um it's it was
widespread across europe um you know
four day weeks or shorter work days or
longer lunches
um these are these are not uncommon
although the last decade has seen a
rollback of a lot of that as as
neoliberalism has been pushing hard on
europe and i'm hopeful that this book
you know
several of my books have been translated
into uh i mean last hours of ancient
sunlight into 17 languages i'm hopeful
that this book can get an audience in
europe as well because you know
neoliberalism is knocking on their door
pretty aggressively right now what's the
path to reversing this in the united
states is it as simple as electing
certain candidates
based on their pursuit of particular
policies or is it is it really bigger
than that
no that's that that's it david it's you
know we need to re-empower labor
elizabeth warren has legislation right
now to do this the national right to
unionize act um you know basically
undoing taft-hartley and and and a whole
series of neoliberal supreme court
decisions
uh number one we need to raise taxes on
the rich on the morbidly rich um the you
know that like i said before the average
billionaire america's pain three three
percent income tax that that's wrong and
that's why you've got you know three men
are putting more wealth in the bottom
half of america and that wealth by the
way is generally not engaged
productively in the economy they're not
spending it you know i had a a
billionaire on my show and he said you
know i'd i buy i probably own the same
number of ju blue jeans as you do i mean
you know i'm i'm about 100 000 times
richer than you but
i'm not going to buy 50 pairs of blue
jeans and uh you know so i'm not helping
the economy any you know so that money
really should be in the economy more
broadly
um so we need to go back to tax rates
that are above 50 percent for people
making more than three or three million
dollars a year is where you know uh
basically fdr had it in today's dollars
and and we need to undo so-called free
trade we need to stop corporations from
the arbitrage of trade of uh labor they
we need to save labor you know the
products sold in the united states
should be made in the united states and
there's a variety of ways to do that
that were laid out by alexander hamilton
in 1793
the congress adopted and that were u.s
policy we had an industrial policy
literally from the george washington
administration to the ronald reagan
administration and reagan blew all that
up and clinton doubled down on it
uh one of the uh kind of pillars of
support for uh neoliberal policies even
if people don't necessarily know the
term neoliberalism you can talk to them
about policies like lower taxes for
businesses for example and they support
these things a lot of this is based on
fundamental misunderstandings of sort of
like how things work and i'll give one
example of that you often hear repeated
oh we need to lower taxes to encourage
businesses to make investments well
business uh expenses are tax deductible
so actually a higher tax rate is more of
an incentive to reinvest because you are
avoiding a higher tax rate by making
tax-deductible investments in your
business it's just a basic thing about
how taxes work brilliantly pointed out
what what do you make of the fact that
these fundamental realities are turned
completely around to gain support of
these policies is it as simple as
educating people
i think so i i really do i you know and
and uh that's why i wrote the book
um you know i'm hoping it's going to be
a fascinating starting point for a lot
of people's conversations because
neoliberalism has guided america when
ronald reagan came into office 65 of
america was in the middle class now it's
down to 45 percent and of that 45 it's
no longer possible to stay in the middle
class with a single wager in the family
um you know and it's no longer possible
to stay out of debt for for at least
half of that forty five percent they're
living on credit card debt mortgage debt
student debt um you know america has
more personal debt than we've ever had
in the history of the of this country
more corporate debt than we've ever had
and obviously more government debt none
of those are healthy things for an
economy all of those are the direct
products of neoliberalism
what do you see as the role of
technology in what may or may not be a
shift away from neoliberalism kind of in
the context of uh not too long ago i
read neil postman's book technopoly
written in the early 90s where he's not
taking an agnostic view about technology
but he's essentially saying in terms of
how it affects economies culture etc
you're going to get the pros and the
cons and it's really about management
and regulation and not about suppressing
a technology which he argued is is more
or less inevitable how does modern
technology social media etc
impact the culture around our economic
systems and things like the future of
neoliberalism
well
technology itself i mean this this is
not an area where the lights would jump
in and say hooray this is our cause
technology itself is kind of agnostic
with regard to neoliberalism and vice
versa however social media had you know
i mean more than half of americans now
get their news primarily from facebook
yeah
pretty damn shocking
social media is a relatively cheap place
to to spread a message and
neoliberalism has made a small number of
people and a small number of
corporations
mind-bogglingly rich i mean richer than
the pharaohs richer than any king or
kingdom in the history of the world
the british royal family had you know
being worth 14 billion dollars are
pikers they're a joke compared to some
of the billionaires in the united states
so these guys pouring millions of
dollars into ads and trolls and
professional bloggers as it were on
social media and facebook on twitter on
instagram on i mean you you name it tik
tok
um this has been going on for some time
and will continue to go on they may not
have hired these people to say hey
you're going to promote neoliberalism it
tends to be more focused you're going to
be the guy who's you know the grover
norquist is going to talk about never
raising taxes on billionaires you're
going to be the guy who talks about how
evil unions are body blah and you're
going to be the guy who talks about how
we've got to have free trade or you know
else the world is going to collapse etc
etc um so you know to the extent that
technology plays a role in this it's
it's largely limited to the role of
propaganda is neoliberal neoliberalism
self-reinforcing in the sense that
by its very nature
it puts many people in a position
of not being able to take a day off from
work because they can't afford to lose
the wages their health insurance is at
risk in order to protest the very system
that created those conditions and it
that in that sense it reinforces itself
yeah and not only that it follows on
the uh the opinions and goals of the
early advocates of neoliberalism
particularly barry goldwater and william
f buckley back in 1951 russell kirk
wrote this book the conservative mind i
write about this my book on oligarchy
and he suggested and
that you know the the american middle
class was growing too fast and 51 you
know we were our middle class was larger
than any in the world it was growing
really really rapidly it was still only
20 30 percent of americans but it was
growing it was growing faster than rich
people were getting rich
and and he wrote that at a certain point
the middle class is going to be large
enough and and people are going to be no
longer afraid of poverty enough
that you're going to see three
consequences young people are going to
start to find their elders which will
produce social chaos women are are going
to forget that their their primary
places in the in the kitchen in the
bedroom which is going to create social
chaos and minorities are going to forget
that they have a place in society at the
bottom they're supposed to be the maids
and the janitors and that's going to
cause social chaos when when they start
demanding you know access to the
boardroom and media and things
um he didn't explicitly lay it out quite
like that many of his followers did but
he he established the frame in that book
and you know at the time in 61 in 51
when he proposed this everybody thought
he was a crackpot except for buckley and
goldwater
but by the time you know 1967 rolled
around and you know young people like me
at that time were burning our draft
cards women were burning their bras and
this went uh you know doubled down in 72
when the supreme court legalized birth
control in 73 when they legalized
abortion women demanding access to the
workplace and of course the civil rights
movement was really you know roaring in
the 60s and 70s
and at that point republicans started
looking around going holy crap russell
kirk was right and so part of reagan's
mandate when he came into office when
the middle class was 65 percent of
america and was defying the powers to
openly define the power structures of
this country was to cut the middle class
down to size and neoliberalism was the
perfect tool to do that and that's
exactly what happened as i mentioned you
know our middle class is no longer the
middle it's you know it's it's no longer
65 percent of americans 45 percent of
america and it's in debt as it is so
those students have shut up because
they're in debt the the women are you
know right now in a pitched battle
you know over abortion specifically but
over women's rights more generally and
the civil rights movement rolls on too
and and we're seeing all the pushback
against that in right-wing channels like
fox news
we've been speaking about tom hartman's
latest book the hidden history of
neoliberalism how reaganism gutted
america and how to restore its greatness
tom always appreciate your time and your
insights
thank you david it's such a pleasure and
an honor to be on your program i really
appreciate you inviting me thank you